when i was a kid a million years ago one
of my favorite childhood movies that
scared the heck out of me was the
witches
[Music]
yeah this was a kid's movie so when i
heard hbo max was remaking it with the
director of back to the future
i was like we're sending you back to the
future
and i thought it would be fun to see all
the crazy differences between the 1990
original and the
2020 remake in this video we'll be
taking a look at both versions to see
what sets them apart and
don't worry if you haven't read the book
i haven't either because i can't read
but before we begin
take a moment to smash that like and
subscribe button to prevent child
cruelty and right off the bat
our first big difference is how the
story starts in the original
it's the grandmother who narrates
warning us of the evils of witches
telling us a story about a young girl
who was trapped by a witch in a painting
this story scared me so much as a kid i
went around the house looking to see if
any of the people in our paintings move
the 2020 version not only skips this
story but replaces it with one
entirely new showing us how
grandmother's friend alice was turned
into a chicken by the grand high witch
when she was a child another huge
difference from the original is
who narrates this intro it's not grandma
but our hero mouse
all grown up voiced by chris rock and
we'll get into why they made that
decision a little bit later on in the
video
both stories center around a young boy
in the original he's called luke but the
remake he's simply called hero boy
unlike the original heroboy is actually
involved in the car crash that kills his
parents spurring his grandmother to come
and take care of him
whereas in the original luke is babysat
by his grandmother while his parents go
off to a fancy dinner and get in a crash
in fact in the remake we never even see
his parents
there are also some drastic changes when
it comes to time and location the remake
opting to set the story in 1968
alabama near the gulf of mexico the
hotel where they meet the witches is
called the grand orleans imperial island
hotel while the original starts in
norway then moves to england the
majority of it taking place at a hotel
called the excelsior its time period is
never disclosed in the film but it's
safe to say
it's set anywhere from 1983 the date the
book was published to 1990 the year the
film came out
in the original we see luke spend about
one scene where he's sad about the death
of his parents whereas in the remake
it's a whole part of establishing his
relationship
with his grandmother she's the one who
gets him out of his sadness even making
him some delicious cornbread which he
says is
just like a cake and i can't help but
think that's a fun nod to the cake
grandma bakes luke and the original the
remake also heavily uses music from the
era to better situate ourselves in the
time something the original doesn't use
it all likely because it's supposed to
be set sometime
fairly modern another great difference
is our introduction of the first
witch in the original she tries to lure
luke down from his tree fort by offering
him candy and the opportunity to see her
snake
because what little boy doesn't like
snakes in the remake we meet this witch
in the general store but she's quickly
scared off by grandma
and this leads to one of the biggest
differences in the two films how they
end up at the hotel
in the original grandma gets diabetes
and they think it would be fun to take
some much needed rest at a swanky
seaside hotel
the new version i think does a better
job here with the grandmother finding
out a witches after her grandson so they
should get away for a bit in an effort
to shake her off she says once a witch
comes into your life
it never leaves you which is something
never mentioned in the original now the
grandma here also comes down with some
sort of illness which is seen through
her cough but grandma explains that's
likely a curse the witch put on her and
it eventually goes away
in both versions the boy receives a pet
mouse but where it goes from there
changes entirely in the original he gets
two mice william and mary and they
aren't that integral to the story in
fact when luke and bruno turn into mice
they can't talk to them in the remake
however there is only one mouse daisy
and they can talk to her because she
like them was transformed into a mouse
by a witch her real name is
mary a nod to one of luke's mice in the
original at the hotel we meet the owners
one you may recognize as stanley tucci
who also worked with anne hathaway in
the devil wears prada and the other
rowan atkinson or as you may know him mr
bean their roles are largely the same
however there's this totally weird
subplot in the original where mr bean is
boinking one of the maids which
somehow didn't make it into the remake
come on i thought this was hbo
and here we can just see the difference
in the signage for the members of the
international society for the prevention
of cruelty to children they get these
creepy ass mannequins while the original
gets this small sign
it's here we have our first sighting of
the grand high witch and there are a ton
of differences between anne hathaway's
version
and angelica houston's although both
have a distinctly european
accent their physical features and
powers vary drastically
fun fact it's heavily implied the grand
high witch is norwegian
as legends say she was hatched on the
frozen tundra of norway as a matter of
fact the beginning of the original has
credits over the frozen norwegian
mountains you'll notice the witches here
wear
fancy high heels when in the original
it's explicitly stated they wear plain
shoes to make it more comfortable for
their deformed feet
they have no toes their hands although
in both versions covered by gloves
differ in what's underneath and
hathaway's witch has deformed
three-finger claws while in the original
the witch's hands are usually just warty
and gross
now even though they totally power up
the grand high witch in the remake i
gotta go with the original here for the
sheer practical effects
it's a giant transformation that took
hours of makeup and prosthetics and it's
super creepy it also shows us just how
different the grand high witch is from
the others you'll also notice this
green smoke used in the original which
they've turned to purple in the remake
along with anne hathaway's joker-like
smile she has super strength powers the
ability to extend her hands
and the biggest change levitation yeah
she totally flies around the conference
room i see how they couldn't do
this in the original i mean imagine
watching this thing fly around the
difference here between
practical and computer generated effects
also extends to the mice there's just a
charm to practical effects which i love
in the original they use a combination
of real mice and prosthetics to make the
mice talk but the remake is all cgi
in the original luke manages to escape
the conference room and there's this
hilarious chase sequence where the grand
eye witch pushes a baby carriage down a
cliff to murder it don't worry it
survives but luke is later captured when
he returns to the hotel while the remake
makes it really simple and the boy is
discovered while watching bruno being
turned into a mouse
again i prefer the practical effects
here of bruno but let me know what you
like in the comments below
as the boy bruno and daisy make their
escape the high witch extends her hands
which are
cut by a fan a scene that never happens
in the original they eventually make
their way to grandma and are able to
steal a vial of the potion which turns
people into mice in the original the
vials are hidden in a book
but the remake has them out in the open
chilling in ice buckets the original
also has a scene where luke is
almost killed by the witch's cat and i'm
glad they took this out as they saved
this
for a new act 3 which i'll get into in a
bit it's here near the end of the film
that the
two versions start to differ extremely
the finale in the original sees the
witches
including the grand high witch eat the
potion lace soup
and all of them turn into mice even the
grand high witch turns into this
ugly thing the soups themselves are
totally different the original opting
for a fine crest soup while their remake
goes for a split pee
one character who i think has two or
three lines in the remake is bruno's dad
mr
jenkins in the original he's a much
larger character with his own scenes
and it's even hinted at that he's a
cheater and he continually makes
advances on the grand high witch
no wonder they left that out now we're
coming up to what i think is the biggest
difference of the two films
the grand hi which doesn't eat her soup
like she does in the original
paving the way to an entirely new ending
in which the mice and grandma have to
take her on
one on one and i actually kinda like it
since they use the mousetraps which they
set up earlier in the film to catapult
the boy over the witch's head
throwing the potion in her mouth and not
only that she turns into this hideous
rat
there's a cool chase sequence with all
these mouse traps going off and she's
eventually put in a see-through ice
bucket similar to what she's trapped in
in the original how she dies however is
totally different as she is eaten or at
least
attacked by her own cat off screen the
original film ends with luke going home
as a mouse
without bruno and one of the witches
becoming a good witch
turns him back into a boy the remake
however goes in a completely different
direction similar to the book and that
the mice
never get turned back to their original
form bruno daisy and the boys spend
their remaining years teaching other
kids about witches
grandma takes the money from the high
witch's trunk to take them on trips
around the world
and another difference is this notebook
found in the chest
in the original it contains names of all
the witches living in america but the
remake has it as all the witches living
in the world now i know i glossed over
some of the more obvious or
obscure differences but i want to know
what you thought of these two
films does this remake surpass the
original or does the original still
reign supreme thanks for watching
everyone be sure to like and subscribe
and share and come and follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much